best comedy series at the 2022 canadian
screen awards also the most nominated
series of the year can we just let that
sink in for a minute it's affirming it's
just it just affirms that these stories
matter that
you know
helping people see themselves is like a
super important and meaningful endeavor
awards like this this kind of
recognition i think just sends a clear
message that these stories will resonate
across any and all gender race
age you know and
that's a really special thing i think to
talk about with the show like this and i
think that's
huge
that
people not involved maybe not queer
themselves not don't know a queer person
in their lives
saw this show
and
connected with the humanity of it
your father is coming on the next flight
he can find
he wants to fix you
what's beautiful about this show is that
yes there is queerness genderqueerness
trans trans femininity
but they're people
mother i am not going up for them
you can
there are consequences to our actions
subby
i know when we last spoke a lot it was
kind of sinking in a bit being the first
south asian queer muslim actor to star
in a canadian prime time television
series what do you think that means to
queer people across canada i think this
is evidence that leads who look like me
can exist i do think that
where we're going is is to really
see our bodies our identities assuming
more kind of leadership roles on
projects and i'm really happy to be a
part of a movement that pushes that
forward